Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join Carthaginians and theirs, on these conditions. The Romans and their allies shall not sail beyond the promontory just north of Carthage, unless compelled to by storm or by enemy action. If any of them are swept by winds beyond it, they shall not buy or remove anything more than is required for the repair of the ship or for sacrifice, and they shall depart within five days. If any Roman enters the Carthaginian sphere of influence in Italy, he shall enjoy equal rights with others. As regards those Latin peoples who are not subject to the Romans, the Carthaginians shall not have
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入迦太基人及其盟友的行列，条件如下：罗马人及其盟友不得航行至迦太基以北的海角之外，除非因风暴或敌方行动所迫。如果他们中有任何人被风吹至该海角之外，除修理船只或祭祀所需外，不得购买或带走任何东西，并须在五天内离开。如果任何罗马人进入迦太基在意大利的影响范围，他应享有与其他所有人平等的权利。至于那些不隶属于罗马人的拉丁民族，迦太基人不得与
dealings with any of these cities and should they capture one of them they are to deliver it up to the romans undamaged should they enter the region bearing arms they are not to spend more than a single night there so that might sound a little bit obscure but actually that is an enormously fascinating historical document because that is the detail of the very first treaty signed by the future superpowers of the mediterranean the great powers that have dominated the world's imagination for so long and they are carthage and rome and that was signed in the year 509 BC. And the text comes from a bronze tablet kept in the capital, in Rome. And Tom Holland, I believe I'm right in saying that it's a Latin so ancient and obscure that nobody knows, well, somebody
他们中的任何城市进行交易，如果他们占领了其中一座城市，应将其完好无损地移交给罗马人；如果他们携带武器进入该地区，不得在那里停留超过一个晚上。这听起来可能有点晦涩，但实际上这是一份极其迷人的历史文献，因为它详细记录了未来地中海超级大国——那些长期主宰世界想象力的伟大强权——签署的第一份条约，它们就是迦太基和罗马，签署于公元前509年。这段文字出自保存在罗马卡比托利欧山的一块青铜板。汤姆·霍兰，我想我没说错吧，这种拉丁语非常古老且晦涩，以至于没人知道，好吧，也许有人
must know, but very few people know how to decipher it. Is that right? It is an amazing, amazing text, and it's recorded by Polybius, who we've been talking about, this Greek who writes a history of the great wars that are fought between Rome and Carthage. He reports, yes, that this text is very, very hard for people to decipher. But obviously, the Romans keep it because they know that it is an absolutely key historical document. It really is. It's amazing. All the stuff that we've been talking about in previous episodes about Carthage, we're dependent on Greeks writing stuff about two centuries before or whatever, but this seems to be an authentic record of the
一定知道，但很少有人能解读它。是这样吗？这确实是一份令人惊叹的文献，它由我们一直在谈论的波利比乌斯记录下来，这位希腊人撰写了关于罗马与迦太基之间伟大战争的历史。他确实提到，这份文本对人们来说非常、非常难以解读。但显然，罗马人保留了它，因为他们知道这是一份绝对关键的历史文献。确实如此。这太神奇了。我们在之前的剧集中谈论的所有关于迦太基的内容，都依赖于希腊人在两百年前或更早之前写下的东西，但这似乎是一份真实的记录，记录了
dealings between Carthage and this emergent power in central Italy, this city called Rome, which really has not intruded at all on the imaginations of outside peoples until this point. So at this point, they're not the great superpowers, right? They're absolutely not a great superpower. No, they're absolutely not. And it's fascinating because it does kind of give an insight into what we were talking in the previous episode about how Carthage in the, so this is the sixth century, is kind of maintaining its power. It's a commercial empire. And so it is trying to arrange treaties with all kinds of different powers. You know, they don't have to be superpowers. You know, they can be kind of minor
迦太基与意大利中部这个新兴势力——那个叫罗马的城市——之间的往来，直到此时，这个城市在外部民族的想象中几乎没有任何存在感。所以，此时他们还不是伟大的超级大国，对吧？他们绝对不是超级大国。不，绝对不是。这很有趣，因为它确实让我们深入了解了我们在上一集讨论的内容，即迦太基在公元前六世纪是如何维持其权力的。它是一个商业帝国。因此，它试图与各种不同的势力安排条约。你知道，它们不必是超级大国。它们可以是像罗马那样的次要
powers like Rome. Yeah. So just Tom, to recap, because obviously this is a Monday episode and lots of people might not have heard the series from last week. So remind us who the Carthaginians are, where they came from and where Carthage even is. So Carthage is the most powerful and the richest city in the 6th, the 5th, the 4th centuries BC. It's very near where Tunis is now, so it's in North Africa, on that kind of point of Africa pointing up towards Sicily. And Carthage, at this point, when this treaty is signed, its prime interest is in keeping the Greeks out of the Western Mediterranean. The Carthaginians have lots of commercial interests.
势力。是的。那么汤姆，简单回顾一下，因为这显然是周一的节目，很多人可能没听过上周的系列节目。所以请提醒我们迦太基人是谁，他们来自哪里，迦太基到底在哪里。迦太基是公元前6、5、4世纪最强大、最富有的城市。它就在现在突尼斯附近，所以它位于北非，在非洲那个指向西西里的尖角上。在签署这份条约时，迦太基的首要利益是将希腊人挡在地中海西部之外。迦太基人有大量的商业利益。
We know this, for instance, because not far north of Rome in this period, there's a town called Caeri, which belongs to a people called the Etruscans. They have a coastal settlement that is so full of Carthaginian merchants that it's actually called Punicum. So Punicus is the Latin word for Carthaginian. And the Etruscans are kind of mysterious, powerful people at this point. They have a famously indecipherable language. They have a tremendous genius for reading the future. So they're experts in kind of reading the entrails of animals and all that kind of thing. And they seem to have had a delightful domestic life. So women have a very high status and there are all these kind of wonderful funerary sculptures of husbands and wives sitting on
我们知道这一点，例如，在这一时期罗马以北不远处，有一个叫卡埃雷（Caeri）的城镇，属于一个叫伊特鲁里亚人的民族。他们有一个沿海定居点，里面住满了迦太基商人，以至于它实际上被称为“Punicum”。所以“Punicus”是拉丁语中“迦太基人”的意思。伊特鲁里亚人在当时是一群神秘而强大的民族。他们拥有一种著名的、无法解读的语言。他们有一种解读未来的惊人天赋。所以他们是解读动物内脏之类的专家。他们似乎有着令人愉悦的家庭生活。女性地位很高，而且有各种各样的精美丧葬雕塑，描绘了丈夫和妻子坐在
couches, having a lovely time as though they're kind of sat down watching the TV or something. And so they're simultaneously mysterious people. But you know, when you look at the sculptures that the Etruscans did, you feel almost like you know them. And in this period, Rome is not an Etruscan city, but culturally, and some have argued militarily, it may be kind of subject, certainly, to Etruscan influence. And so for this reason, it makes sense for the Carthaginians. They're allied with the Etruscans against the Greeks,
沙发上，享受着美好时光，就像他们坐在那里看电视一样。所以他们同时也是神秘的民族。但是，当你看到伊特鲁里亚人制作的雕塑时，你会觉得几乎认识他们。在这一时期，罗马还不是一座伊特鲁里亚城市，但在文化上，有些人认为在军事上，它可能在某种程度上受到伊特鲁里亚的影响。因此，对迦太基人来说，这很有意义。他们与伊特鲁里亚人结盟对抗希腊人，
and it makes sense for them to sign a treaty with Rome as well. So at this point, what are we, the 6th century? In the last episode, we talked loads about the Carthaginians and the Greeks squabbling for control of Sicily. So by this point, the 6th century BC, they're expanding their influence into mainland Italy as well. Is that right? But not in an imperialist way. They're trying to construct kind of trade treaties.
与罗马签署条约对他们来说也很有意义。那么此时，我们是在公元前6世纪吗？在上一集中，我们谈了很多关于迦太基人和希腊人为争夺西西里岛控制权而发生的争吵。所以到了公元前6世纪，他们也在将影响力扩展到意大利本土。是这样吗？但不是以帝国主义的方式。他们试图建立某种贸易条约。
They're kind of like Liz Truss going around, you know, global Carthage. With a little bit more success, I think it's fair to say. With a little bit more success, yes. So basically they're trying to ensure that their sphere of influence is protected. So that's why the Romans are agreeing not, for instance, to go crashing into Africa. That's why there are kind of requirements that their ships are not allowed to intrude into Carthaginian waters. But equally, the Carthaginians are saying that they will respect Rome's power. And it offers a glimpse of Rome at the beginning of her career. And this is fascinating because, of course, we know what
他们有点像特拉斯（Liz Truss）到处跑，你知道，全球化的迦太基。我想说，他们取得的成功稍微多一点。是的，成功稍微多一点。所以基本上他们是在试图确保他们的势力范围受到保护。这就是为什么罗马人同意，例如，不冲进非洲。这就是为什么有要求他们的船只不得闯入迦太基水域的规定。但同样，迦太基人也表示他们会尊重罗马的权力。它让我们得以一窥罗马职业生涯初期的样子。这很迷人，因为当然，我们知道
is going to happen with Rome. We know that Rome is going to become the supreme carnival, the apex predator of antiquity. What we're seeing here is the infancy of this predator. I think that we are so attuned to the idea of the Roman Empire just existing, the idea that the Romans are this great military power. But the puzzle is, why are they so successful? What is it about Rome that makes them the city that will emerge as the great rival of Carthage and, spoiler alert, fight three terrible wars that in the long run will culminate in the utter destruction of Carthage. And I think that there are clues here. So certainly Rome is a significant regional power. It clearly has control over, you know, so there's reference there to Latins.
罗马会发生什么。我们知道罗马将成为至高无上的狂欢者，古代的顶级掠食者。我们在这里看到的是这个掠食者的婴儿期。我认为我们太习惯于罗马帝国已经存在、罗马人是这种伟大军事强权的想法了。但谜题是，为什么他们如此成功？罗马有什么特质使他们成为最终崛起为迦太基伟大对手的城市，并且，剧透预警，进行了三场可怕的战争，最终导致了迦太基的彻底毁灭。我认为这里有线索。所以罗马无疑是一个重要的区域强权。它显然对，你知道，所以那里提到了拉丁人。
Latins are Latin speakers, cities around Rome. And there is a sense in this treaty that Rome has established a regional dominance over them. So that's fascinating. But I think even more intriguing is the date of this. So it's 509 BC. This is the date that's given by Polybius. And this is the date that traditionally the Romans saw as being the great change in their city's history from a monarchy to a republican system of government. Oh, this is when they kicked out Tarquin the Proud. Tarquin the Proud. So the story goes that they've had seven kings, you know, descended from Romulus,
拉丁人是讲拉丁语的人，是罗马周围的城市。在这份条约中有一种感觉，即罗马已经对他们建立了区域统治。这很迷人。但我认为更耐人寻味的是它的日期。这是公元前509年。这是波利比乌斯给出的日期。这也是罗马人传统上认为他们的城市历史发生重大变革的日期，即从君主制转变为共和制政府。哦，这就是他们赶走傲慢者塔克文的时候。傲慢者塔克文。故事是这样的，他们有七位国王，你知道，是罗慕路斯的后裔，
the founder of the city. Tarquin is the seventh. He has a son called by Macaulay, the great Victorian writer in the 19th century, False Sextus. False Sextus. False Sextus. And he rapes a noble Roman virgin. She kills herself in front of her father. And the Roman aristocracy and the people are so appalled by the crime that Sextus has committed that they throw both Sextus and Tarquin out of Rome.
城市的奠基人。塔克文是第七位。他有一个儿子，被19世纪伟大的维多利亚时代作家麦考利称为“伪塞克斯图斯”。伪塞克斯图斯。伪塞克斯图斯。他强奸了一位高贵的罗马处女。她在父亲面前自杀了。罗马贵族和人民对塞克斯图斯犯下的罪行感到震惊，以至于他们把塞克斯图斯和塔克文都赶出了罗马。
There's an attempt by an Etruscan king called Lars Percena to try and take Rome back. But the Etruscan ranks are kept at bay by Horatius and two of his friends who stand on the bridge. The bridge, love Horatius on the bridge. While the other Romans hack it down, two of the defenders scarper back. Horatius stands there. The bridge comes crashing down. Horatius in full armour jumps into the Tiber. You know, is he going to drown? No, he makes it to the Roman side. And even the ranks of Tuscany could scarce forbear to cheer. So all very dramatic, very novelistic, possibly not entirely true. What, Tom? Don't do this. Don't do this. You're better than that.
一位名叫拉尔斯·波塞纳（Lars Porsena）的伊特鲁里亚国王试图夺回罗马。但伊特鲁里亚军队被霍拉蒂乌斯（Horatius）和他的两个朋友挡住了，他们站在桥上。那座桥，爱死桥上的霍拉蒂乌斯了。当其他罗马人砍断桥梁时，两名守卫逃了回去。霍拉蒂乌斯站在那里。桥轰然倒塌。全副武装的霍拉蒂乌斯跳进了台伯河。你知道，他会淹死吗？不，他成功游到了罗马一侧。甚至托斯卡纳的军队也几乎忍不住要欢呼。所以这一切都非常戏剧性，非常小说化，可能并不完全真实。什么，汤姆？别这样。别这样。你比这更好。
But Dominic, the fact that this treaty is signed in 509 suggests that the traditional dating is probably accurate, that something radical did happen in 509. Because otherwise the Carthaginians would not have needed to regularize their relations at Rome. Yes. So probably this is an attempt to reset relationships after what effectively has been a kind of revolution. Now, in later generations, and so particularly the time when the Romans are fighting the Carthaginians, and they are trying to make sense of their own past. The story they tell about how the Republic comes into being is that the king is expelled and his powers get divided up between two elected magistrates called consuls. And you remember,
但是多米尼克，这份条约签署于公元前509年的事实表明，传统的年代测定可能是准确的，即公元前509年确实发生了激进的事情。因为否则迦太基人就不需要规范他们与罗马的关系了。是的。所以这可能是在经历了一场有效的革命之后，试图重置关系。现在，在后来的几代人中，特别是在罗马人与迦太基人作战、试图理解他们自己的过去时。他们讲述的关于共和国如何诞生的故事是，国王被驱逐，他的权力被分配给两名当选的行政长官，称为执政官。你还记得，
we talked in the previous episode that the Carthaginians actually have something quite similar called suffetes. Are the Romans ripping off the Carthaginian system, Tom? Well, also the marker of a consul is that he wears a purple bordered robe. And of course, the dye comes from Carthage. Mollusks, Carthaginian mollusks, crushed mollusks. Oh my word. You can tell I've been paying attention to the last two episodes. Having said that, I mean, I think the Carthaginians are not influencing this at all.
我们在上一集谈到迦太基人实际上有一种非常相似的东西，叫做“苏菲特”（suffetes）。汤姆，罗马人是在抄袭迦太基的制度吗？嗯，执政官的标志是他穿着紫边长袍。当然，染料来自迦太基。软体动物，迦太基的软体动物，压碎的软体动物。天哪。你可以看出我一直在关注前两集。话虽如此，我的意思是，我认为迦太基人根本没有影响这一点。
It's being instituted for very Roman reasons. The idea being that the consuls are elected for one year, they each keep an eye on the other. And it's this whole idea that no one man in the wake of the expulsion of the monarchy should be allowed to seize absolute power. This is the great principle of the Republic. And according to the Roman traditional accounts of what happens in the century after the founding of the Republic. According to the Roman traditional accounts of what happens in the century after the founding of the Republic, it works. Roman historians say that there are social convulsions, that there are demands from the mass of the people for improved civic rights, lots of constitutional reforms. But the Republic, according to Roman historians, does not implode into civil war, into revolutionary
它是出于非常罗马的原因而设立的。其理念是执政官任期一年，他们互相监督。这就是在君主制被驱逐后，不应允许任何一个人夺取绝对权力的整个理念。这是共和国的伟大原则。根据罗马关于共和国成立后一个世纪所发生事情的传统记载。根据罗马关于共和国成立后一个世纪所发生事情的传统记载，它奏效了。罗马历史学家说，发生了社会动荡，大众要求改善公民权利，进行了大量的宪法改革。但根据罗马历史学家，共和国并没有陷入内战、革命
activity. And this is because the Romans will demonstrate a genius for being simultaneously very, very innovative, but very, very traditional. You know, you said this is very Roman reasons and all that. Isn't it possible that you only think that because Rome is so successful? So this could be a widely practiced thing or it could be something because you said in the last episode that we knew very little about Carthage's constitutional arrangements and Carthage is far more influential than Rome at this point is it not possible that the Romans took this from Carthage then Rome became tremendously successful so we say oh well of course this is very Roman keeping competition within bounds all that kind
活动。这是因为罗马人将展现出一种既非常、非常创新，又非常、非常传统的天赋。你知道，你说这是非常罗马的原因等等。难道你不觉得你之所以这么想，仅仅是因为罗马太成功了吗？所以这可能是一件广泛实践的事情，或者可能是因为你在上一集中说我们对迦太基的宪法安排知之甚少，而且迦太基在这一点上比罗马更有影响力，难道罗马人没有从迦太基那里学到这一点，然后罗马变得非常成功，所以我们说，哦，好吧，这当然是非常罗马的，将竞争控制在范围内，所有这些
of thing so Roman you know the predatory course, this is very Roman, keeping competition within bounds, all that kind of thing. So Roman, the predatory ruthlessness of it, very Roman. But we're only thinking that because we're projecting backwards, as it were. I think you are absolutely right that there is a problem with taking what the Romans said about the first century of the Republic as being historically true. But I think that what they believed matters for understanding how they will behave in the wars against Carthage, because they do have a sense of themselves as being distinctive. And it's evident that in their ability to project violence and their refusal
事情，所以罗马，你知道那种掠夺性的无情，非常罗马。但我们之所以这么想，是因为我们在向后投射。我认为你绝对正确，将罗马人关于共和国第一个世纪的说法视为历史事实是有问题的。但我认为他们所相信的东西对于理解他们将如何在与迦太基的战争中表现很重要，因为他们确实有一种自己与众不同的感觉。很明显，他们投射暴力的能力和他们拒绝
ever to accept surrender, there is something very, very strange about it. So in that sense, I think it's worth just looking at how the Romans, in the period when they are fighting the Carthaginians, how they understood their past and how they explained what they were about. So Polybius, for instance, this Greek historian who we've been talking about, he is trying to make sense of this puzzle. How is it that the Romans have defeated Carthage, have gone on to overthrow the various Macedonian kingdoms. I mean, how have they done it? And his explanation is that the masses are basically incredibly superstitious, that the elites are very cynical. But I think that this is a very Greek perspective,
接受投降的态度，其中有一些非常、非常奇怪的东西。所以从这个意义上说，我认为值得看看罗马人在与迦太基人作战的时期，是如何理解他们的过去以及他们是如何解释自己的。所以波利比乌斯，例如，我们一直在谈论的这位希腊历史学家，他试图理解这个谜题。罗马人是如何击败迦太基，并继续推翻各种马其顿王国的。我的意思是，他们是怎么做到的？他的解释是，大众基本上极其迷信，精英们非常愤世嫉俗。但我认为这是一个非常希腊的视角，
because just as the Greeks don't really understand Carthage, they don't really understand Rome either. And the truth is that the Republic, like Carthage, is not a Greek state. Greek states are regularly being shattered by civil wars, by revolutions, by social tensions. Rome genuinely seems to be impervious to these kinds of disasters. You do not see the blood of its citizens being spilled on the streets in civil strife. And that is because I think the Romans authentically have an ideal of shared citizenship. It's incredibly, well, one might say sacral to them. And our word republic comes from res publica. It means kind of public business. So every Roman, by the time that the wars against Carthage are being fought, every Roman has this ideal that his sense of self-worth exists in the context of what his fellows think about him.
因为正如希腊人并不真正了解迦太基一样，他们也不真正了解罗马。事实是，共和国像迦太基一样，不是一个希腊国家。希腊国家经常被内战、革命、社会紧张局势所摧毁。罗马似乎确实对这些灾难免疫。你不会看到它的公民在内战中流血街头。我认为这是因为罗马人确实有一种共享公民身份的理想。这对他们来说非常，嗯，可以说神圣。我们的“共和国”（republic）一词来自“res publica”。它意味着某种公共事务。所以每个罗马人，在与迦太基的战争进行时，每个罗马人都有一种理想，即他的自我价值感存在于他的同伴如何看待他的背景下。
So the Romans have this word, onestas, which means moral excellence, but it also means reputation. The two are kind of indistinguishable. The Romans don't separate the two out. There are basically two corollaries of this. So the first is that the stuff about the consuls, these kind of rival magistrates who are simultaneously kind of working together. This is what every Roman wants. And this is the supreme honor. And every time that there is a kind of a civic convulsion in Rome, more magistracies are given, meaning that there are more prizes, meaning that there are more opportunities for Romans to rise up through the ranks, to gain honor. And so the effect of that
所以罗马人有一个词，“onestas”，意思是道德卓越，但也意味着声誉。两者基本上是不可区分的。罗马人并没有把两者分开。这基本上有两个推论。第一个是关于执政官的事情，这些相互竞争的行政长官同时在某种程度上合作。这是每个罗马人想要的。这是至高无上的荣誉。每当罗马发生某种公民动荡时，就会给予更多的行政职位，这意味着有更多的奖项，意味着罗马人有更多的机会通过等级制度上升，获得荣誉。所以其效果是
is to kind of channel the ambition for glory that Roman society seems to have encouraged and keep it within civic bounds. So it works for the benefit of the whole mass of the people, for the res publica, for the Republic, rather than kind of fragmenting outwards and setting powerful men against powerful men. So that's one corollary of it. Every Roman, right from the lowest, right the way up to the top, is keen for the kind of glory that is judged by your fellow citizens. So it gives an incredibly powerful civic identity. But of course, this is terrible news for the Roman's neighbours, because how do you obtain glory? Basically by going out and fighting and conquering your neighbours. And so every citizen is expected to fight. So the word legion, a legio is a levy.
将罗马社会似乎鼓励的对荣耀的野心引导并保持在公民范围内。所以它造福于全体人民，造福于“res publica”，造福于共和国，而不是向外分裂，让权势人物对抗权势人物。所以这是它的一个推论。每个罗马人，从最底层的到最高层的，都渴望那种由你的同胞评判的荣耀。所以它赋予了一种极其强大的公民身份。但当然，这对罗马人的邻居来说是个可怕的消息，因为你如何获得荣耀？基本上是通过出去战斗和征服你的邻居。所以每个公民都被期望去战斗。所以“军团”（legion）这个词，“legio”是一个征兵。
Every citizen is expected when war is summoned to go out into the campus marshes, the plain of Mars, which stretches outside the walls of Rome, and to be enrolled in a legio, in a legion. And this commitment never to accept disrespect, never to accept dishonour, is manifest in what to their enemy seems a kind of terrifying commitment to violence. So when the Romans capture a city, it's not just that has kind of resisted them, that has refused to surrender or has committed some kind of perceived crime against Rome. The legions will not only take the city by storm, but they will kill every living creature within it. So, you know, dismembered dogs, the heads of cattle and
每个公民在战争被召唤时，都被期望走到罗马城墙外的战神广场（campus marshes），并被编入一个“legio”，即一个军团。这种绝不接受不尊重、绝不接受耻辱的承诺，体现在对他们的敌人来说似乎是一种可怕的暴力承诺。所以当罗马人占领一座城市时，不仅仅是因为它以某种方式抵抗了他们，拒绝投降或对罗马犯下了某种被认为的罪行。军团不仅会强攻这座城市，而且会杀死其中的每一个活物。所以，你知道，肢解的狗，牛和
horses kind of littering the streets. So it's terrifying, but they're not barbarians. They're fighting in a kind of coherent civic body. It's just that this is an utterly lethal predator. I'm not convinced that's much consolation to the dogs, but anyway, there you go. No, no consolation at all. I mean, you would not want to be a dog in a city that has offended the Romans. No. I mean, absolutely terrifying. So with
马的头颅散落在街道上。所以这很可怕，但他们不是野蛮人。他们在一个连贯的公民团体中战斗。只是这是一个极其致命的掠食者。我不认为这对狗来说是什么安慰，但无论如何，就是这样。不，根本没有安慰。我的意思是，你不会想成为一座冒犯了罗马人的城市里的狗。不。我的意思是，绝对可怕。所以对于
those who resist them, they are terrifying. But there is also, again, and this is something that contrasts with the Greeks. You think of a city like Sparta that is so xenophobic that they won't even allow strangers into their city. The Romans are very, very generous with their citizenship. And again, this bewilders the Greeks. So according to legends, you think of Athens, the story there is that people rise up from the soil, that the Athenians are born from the earth of Attica. The Romans freely admit that when Romulus founded the city, he summoned people from all around, kind of criminals, escaped slaves, whoever, it didn't matter.
那些抵抗他们的人，他们是可怕的。但同样，这也是与希腊人形成对比的地方。你想到像斯巴达这样的城市，它是如此排外，以至于他们甚至不允许陌生人进入他们的城市。罗马人对他们的公民身份非常、非常慷慨。同样，这让希腊人感到困惑。所以根据传说，你想到雅典，那里的故事是人们从土壤中升起，雅典人是雅典土地上出生的。罗马人坦率地承认，当罗慕路斯建立这座城市时，他从四面八方召集了人们，罪犯、逃跑的奴隶，无论谁，都没关系。
These are where the Romans come from according to their own legends. And even the most powerful of dynasties in Rome are perfectly happy to celebrate their immigrant status. So you think of one of the most famous political dynasties in Rome, the Claudians, which will, you know, the Emperor Claudius is descendant of them. According to tradition, this is founded by a guy called Attius Clausus, who migrates to Rome from the hills beyond Rome six years after the founding of the Republic, so in 503. A decade later, he's become consul. From that time on, the Claudians absolutely dominate the lists of consuls. There will be Claudians taking a part throughout the history of the Punic Wars. It's not just kind
根据他们自己的传说，这就是罗马人的来源。即使是罗马最强大的王朝也乐于庆祝他们的移民身份。所以你想到罗马最著名的政治王朝之一，克劳狄家族（Claudians），克劳狄皇帝就是他们的后裔。根据传统，这是由一个叫阿提乌斯·克劳苏斯（Attius Clausus）的人建立的，他在共和国成立六年后的公元前503年从罗马以外的山区迁移到罗马。十年后，他成为了执政官。从那时起，克劳狄家族绝对主宰了执政官名单。在布匿战争的整个历史中，都会有克劳狄家族参与。这不仅仅是
of powerful people or immigrants coming into the city. The Romans are also very, very good at integrating cities that they've defeated. So in the 350s, this is 150 years after that peace treaty that the Romans signed with Carthage. Rome is still the dominant power in central Italy, but then in 340, all the Latin cities rebel against Rome. And basically they're annoyed at being treated as subjects rather than allies. And the Romans defeat this rebellion, but they kind of draw a lesson from it that what had previously been a kind of a league of the Latin cities, kind of like a Latin European union, this is no longer acceptable. Every city is going to have to be treated individually. And so the Romans
权势人物或移民进入城市。罗马人也非常、非常擅长整合他们击败的城市。所以在公元前350年代，这是罗马与迦太基签署和平条约150年后。罗马仍然是意大利中部的统治力量，但在公元前340年，所有拉丁城市都反抗罗马。基本上他们对被视为臣民而不是盟友感到恼火。罗马人击败了这场叛乱，但他们从中吸取了一个教训，即以前那种拉丁城市联盟，有点像拉丁欧洲联盟，不再被接受了。每个城市都必须被单独对待。所以罗马人
divide and rule with the Latin cities. So some are enrolled as Roman citizens. Others are given a kind of subordinate citizenship. Cities that had been inveterately rebellious are treated very harshly. So their walls are razed, their elites are sent into exile. One of them has its entire fleet confiscated. The Romans take the prows of the fleet, which they called rostra, and put them up in the forum, the great central space in Rome, to be a kind of place where orators will go and stand. And this is where we get our word rostra from. And this kind of provides the blueprint that will be followed throughout the entire history of the Roman Empire, that you go in hard against your enemies, but those who are defeated or surrender
对拉丁城市采取分而治之。所以一些人被登记为罗马公民。其他人被给予一种从属的公民身份。那些一贯反叛的城市受到了非常严厉的对待。所以他们的城墙被夷为平地，他们的精英被流放。其中一个城市的所有舰队都被没收了。罗马人拿走了舰队的船头，他们称之为“rostra”，并把它们放在广场上，罗马的伟大中心空间，作为一个演说家站立的地方。这就是我们“rostra”一词的来源。这种方式提供了将在罗马帝国整个历史上遵循的蓝图，即你对敌人采取强硬态度，但那些被击败或投降
or submit, you treat them very, very generously. And perhaps you enroll them as citizens. More citizens mean larger armies. Larger armies mean more conquests. More conquests mean more citizens. So can we draw a contrast with Carthage? So while the Romans are doing all this, what's that? Fourth century BC. Carthage is top dog in the Mediterranean. But does Carthage do anything like this, Tom? Because Carthage obviously has colonies, doesn't it? It has trading stations, it has forts. But has it got any similar history of incorporating? Are the Romans unique in that regard, would you say? I think they are unique. So Carthage has mercenaries. The mercenaries obviously do
或屈服的人，你非常、非常慷慨地对待他们。也许你把他们登记为公民。更多的公民意味着更大的军队。更大的军队意味着更多的征服。更多的征服意味着更多的公民。所以我们能与迦太基进行对比吗？所以当罗马人做所有这些事情时，那是什么？公元前4世纪。迦太基是地中海的老大。但迦太基做过类似的事情吗，汤姆？因为迦太基显然有殖民地，不是吗？它有贸易站，它有堡垒。但它有任何类似的合并历史吗？你会说罗马人在那方面是独一无二的吗？我认为他们是独一无二的。所以迦太基有雇佣兵。雇佣兵显然
not have any civic sense of belonging to a single body, a res publica. And that is a real difference between the Carthaginian and the Roman way of making war. And in the long run, the Roman way of making war will show itself to be much more successful. But war between Rome and Carthage in the middle of the fourth century is still a long way off. And so in 348, a decade before that Latin uprising that I was talking about, there's a second treaty between Rome and Carthage. And it's almost identical to the previous one. And in fact, actually, it's slightly more favourable to Carthage because they specify that Romans are not allowed to, for instance, go and found a colony
没有任何属于单一团体、一个“res publica”的公民意识。这就是迦太基和罗马作战方式之间的真正区别。从长远来看，罗马的作战方式将被证明要成功得多。但罗马和迦太基在公元前4世纪中叶的战争还很遥远。所以在公元前348年，在我谈到的那次拉丁起义前十年，罗马和迦太基之间有了第二次条约。它几乎与前一个一模一样。事实上，它对迦太基稍微有利一些，因为他们规定罗马人不得，例如，去建立一个殖民地
in Sardinia. And the Romans have to accept this. And you may wonder, well, if the Romans are this kind of predator in waiting, this great carnivore, how is it that basically in the space of 150 years since the founding of the Republic, they haven't done better? I mean, what's going on there? And I think that the answer to that is pointing to the point you raised earlier, which is that actually it's not the founding of the Republic that changes everything, but another event. Because I think that the great event, the great turning point happens actually in 390 when Rome is sacked by a great army of Gauls. So the geese. Absolutely, the geese. So the Romans go out to meet this great war band of Gauls. So the geese. Absolutely, the geese. So the Romans go out to meet this
在撒丁岛。罗马人不得不接受这一点。你可能会想，好吧，如果罗马人是这种等待中的掠食者，这种伟大的食肉动物，为什么基本上在共和国成立后的150年里，他们没有做得更好？我的意思是，那里发生了什么？我认为答案指向了你之前提出的观点，即实际上并不是共和国的成立改变了一切，而是另一个事件。因为我认为伟大的事件，伟大的转折点实际上发生在公元前390年，当时罗马被一支伟大的高卢军队洗劫。所以鹅。绝对是，鹅。所以罗马人出去迎接这支伟大的高卢战团。所以鹅。绝对是，鹅。所以罗马人出去迎接这支
great war band of Gauls. They get annihilated at a battle. The anniversary of it will forever be commemorated as the darkest day in the Roman calendar. The Gauls then lay siege to the Capitol. They're climbing up the side of the Capitol. The watchdogs don't bark. The geese hiss. The Capitol is saved. And from that point on, every year on the anniversary of that, the geese on the Capitol will be taken down into the Forum to witness the crucifixion of the guard dogs. So all very odd. But this story doesn't disguise the fact that it was a humiliating defeat, that Rome has to buy off the Gauls. They hand over all their treasure. The Gauls demand more.
伟大的高卢战团。他们在一次战斗中被歼灭。它的周年纪念日将永远被纪念为罗马日历中最黑暗的一天。高卢人随后围攻了卡比托利欧山。他们爬上卡比托利欧山的一侧。看门狗没有叫。鹅在嘶嘶叫。卡比托利欧山得救了。从那时起，每年在周年纪念日，卡比托利欧山上的鹅都会被带到广场，见证看门狗的受刑。所以这一切都很奇怪。但这个故事并没有掩盖这样一个事实，即这是一场羞辱性的失败，罗马不得不收买高卢人。他们交出了所有的财宝。高卢人要求更多。
The Romans object and say that this wasn't in the treaty. And the Gauls famously say, vivictis, woe to the defeated. And this seems to have affected the Romans as the most terrible shock, the most terrible humiliation. And they seem to have resolved that from that point onwards, they would never again accept anyone disrespecting them. And there are a number of brilliant scholarly studies that kind of try to make sense of this by saying that essentially the story of there being this kind of common civic identity that had existed since the Republic is actually not true. That really it's with the defeat by the Gauls that you start to get this integration of the aristocracy and the mass of the people, and this sense of a kind of aggressive, common civic identity and purpose. And so it's in the decades that follow the sack of Rome by the Gauls
罗马人反对并说这不在条约中。高卢人著名地说，“vae victis”，失败者有祸了。这似乎对罗马人产生了最可怕的冲击，最可怕的羞辱。他们似乎下定决心，从那时起，他们绝不再接受任何人不尊重他们。有许多出色的学术研究试图通过说基本上关于共和国以来就存在这种共同公民身份的故事实际上是不真实的来理解这一点。真正的是，随着被高卢人击败，你开始得到这种精英和大众的融合，以及一种侵略性的、共同的公民身份和目的感。所以是在高卢人洗劫罗马后的几十年里
that you seem to see the emergence of a citizen army. So actually before then, is this not Jeremy Alexander's brilliant book, Tom? It is, yes. Yes, which I've been talking to you about. It's just the argument that he makes that Rome was far more divided than we think. And actually it's the trauma of defeat.
你似乎看到了公民军队的出现。所以实际上在那之前，这不是杰里米·亚历山大的那本出色的书吗，汤姆？是的，确实。是的，我一直在和你谈论的那本。这正是他提出的论点，即罗马比我们想象的要分裂得多。实际上是失败的创伤。
Yes. That means they have to bind themselves together into a common civic culture, kind of martial culture and say never again. You know, well,, it's that classic thing of people being brought together. It's the foundation of so many nationalisms, the external threat that provides the glue. Yeah. So the book you mentioned, War and Society in Early Rome, From Warlords to Generals, and that's by Jeremy Armstrong. And his argument is essentially is
是的。这意味着他们必须将自己团结成一种共同的公民文化，某种军事文化，并说绝不再发生。你知道，嗯，这是人们被聚集在一起的经典事情。这是许多民族主义的基础，提供粘合剂的外部威胁。是的。所以你提到的那本书，《早期罗马的战争与社会，从军阀到将军》，那是杰里米·阿姆斯特朗写的。他的论点基本上是
that the elite, so people like Clausus, this ancestor of the Claudians, that these are like kind of superstar galacticos who drift around from top club to top club and don't have any particular loyalty to the club that they're in. What really matters is their own status, their own profile. They're Jordan Henderson, Tom. Yeah, they're kind of Jordan Henderson. And that the mass of the Roman people therefore feel a disconnect from these Galacticos, but that the sack of their city by the Gauls changes that. And the aristocracy, as well as the mass of people, start to have a shared identity of being Roman. And this is where you get the emergence of the aristocracy as a common group of people called the Senate. The
精英，所以像克劳苏斯这样的人，克劳狄家族的祖先，他们就像从顶级俱乐部漂流到顶级俱乐部的超级巨星，对他们所在的俱乐部没有任何特别的忠诚。真正重要的是他们自己的地位，他们自己的形象。他们是乔丹·亨德森，汤姆。是的，他们有点像乔丹·亨德森。因此，罗马大众感到与这些巨星脱节，但他们的城市被高卢人洗劫改变了这一点。贵族以及大众开始拥有作为罗马人的共同身份。这就是你得到贵族作为一个被称为元老院的共同群体出现的地方。
mass of people, they have their assemblies, they have their voice. These are the people who will elect the consuls and the various other magistrates. You have the emergence of the citizen army. You can tell from archaeology that armor is starting to become less showy, which in turn means that it's more affordable. So the mass of people can now afford it. The walls around Rome are renewed and improved. And basically, Rome has become a kind of mutant state. It's a state like no other. And the mutant quality is its absolute refusal ever to suffer humiliation. No Roman from this point on is willing to tolerate a loss of face. And rather than endure humiliation, a Roman will go to any length basically to ensure that that doesn't happen. And so Rome in the wake of the sack by the Gauls has become a state that is kind of uniquely lethal, but from the point of view of the Romans, uniquely glorious. And so the result is that with the suppression of that Latin uprising in 338, Rome now has incredible reserves of manpower because it's enrolled the people of these defeated cities
大众，他们有他们的集会，他们有他们的声音。这些人将选举执政官和其他各种行政长官。你有了公民军队的出现。你可以从考古学中看出盔甲开始变得不那么炫耀，这反过来意味着它更实惠。所以大众现在买得起了。罗马周围的城墙被更新和改进了。基本上，罗马已经变成了一种突变国家。它是一个独一无二的国家。这种突变品质是它绝对拒绝再遭受羞辱。从那时起，没有罗马人愿意容忍丢脸。与其忍受羞辱，罗马人会不惜一切代价基本上确保这种情况不会发生。所以罗马在高卢人洗劫后已经变成了一个在某种程度上独一无二的致命国家，但从罗马人的角度来看，是独一无二的荣耀。所以结果是，随着公元前338年那场拉丁起义的镇压，罗马现在拥有了令人难以置信的人力储备，因为它已经将这些被击败城市的居民登记
into its own citizen body. And that gives it a resource that kind of has elevated it from the level of a regional power, pretty much to the level of Carthage, a level with the Greek kingdoms in the East. Carthage is rich. Carthage is trading all the time. Carthage has loads of money. Does Rome have loads of money? Yeah. I mean, Rome is rich because it's a plunder-based society. So that's how it gets its wealth. It's not a trading society. At this point, it doesn't have a fleet.
进入了自己的公民团体。这给了它一种资源，使它从区域强权的水平提升到了迦太基的水平，与东方的希腊王国处于同一水平。迦太基很富有。迦太基一直在贸易。迦太基有很多钱。罗马有很多钱吗？是的。我的意思是，罗马很富有，因为它是一个基于掠夺的社会。所以这就是它获得财富的方式。它不是一个贸易社会。在这一点上，它没有舰队。
It doesn't have a maritime tradition at all. But of course, what it has that Carthage doesn't have is manpower. And it is manpower that is what you need in this kind of world. The Carthaginians can pay people to fight for them, but the Romans don't need to do that. They have lots of people who are desperate to get out and fight. So when Carthage signed that treaty a decade before, Rome was a secondary power. Now it isn't.
它根本没有海上传统。但当然，它拥有迦太基所没有的东西，那就是人力。而人力正是你在这种世界中需要的。迦太基人可以付钱给人们为他们战斗，但罗马人不需要这样做。他们有很多人渴望出去战斗。所以当迦太基在十年前签署那份条约时，罗马是一个次要强权。现在它不是了。
And the consequences of that for the peoples of Italy and in the long run for the Carthaginians will be devastating. And for the world. And for the world. And for the world. Okay, come back after the break to find out what happens next in this absolutely swashbuckling, blood-drenched story of the rivalry between Rome and Carthage. I'm Marina Hyde.
这对意大利人民以及从长远来看对迦太基人的后果将是毁灭性的。对世界也是。对世界也是。对世界也是。好吧，休息后回来，看看在这个罗马和迦太基之间绝对惊险、血腥的竞争故事中接下来会发生什么。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Now, in general, the Romans rely upon force in all their undertakings
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。现在，总的来说，罗马人在所有的事业中都依赖武力
and consider that having set themselves a task, they are bound to carry it through. And similarly, that nothing is impossible once they have decided to attempt it. So, Tom, I know that's your personal motto, isn't it? And that's from Polybius. Absolutely. Well, it's the motto of the podcast, isn't it? You absolutely believe both in the use of force and that nothing is impossible when you set your mind to it. So that's Polybius talking about the Romans. That's taken them very much at their own estimation, isn't it? It is.
并认为一旦设定了任务，他们就有义务完成它。同样，一旦他们决定尝试，就没有什么是不可能的。所以，汤姆，我知道那是你的个人座右铭，不是吗？那是波利比乌斯说的。绝对是。好吧，那是播客的座右铭，不是吗？你绝对相信武力的使用，也相信当你下定决心时，没有什么是不可能的。所以那是波利比乌斯在谈论罗马人。那是把他们完全按照他们自己的估计来看待，不是吗？是的。
That they're incredibly hard and nothing is beyond them. But bear in mind that Polybius, you know, I mean, he's a Greek who's been taken as a captive to Rome. So he's in a position to appreciate it. But is that true? I mean, let's be honest. Are they invincible? Are they peerless, all those things? Let us look at the evidence.
他们极其强硬，没有什么能难倒他们。但请记住，波利比乌斯，你知道，我的意思是，他是一个被俘虏到罗马的希腊人。所以他处于能够欣赏它的位置。但这真的吗？我的意思是，让我们诚实一点。他们是不可战胜的吗？他们是无与伦比的，所有这些事情吗？让我们看看证据。
So if we accept the thesis that was posited just before the break, that the great turning point is 390 BC, the sack of Rome by the Gauls, and the determination of the Romans from that point on, never again to risk such a humiliation. And maybe it takes them a few decades to forge this new kind of society, one in which the drive for honour is something that can be turned against Rome's neighbours. Well, by the 340s, all the Latin cities around Rome have been utterly subordinated to Roman authority. Lots of them have been enrolled within the citizen body of Rome itself. What happens next? How does this reliance upon force that Polybius identifies, how does it manifest itself in the context of Italian politics? So south of Latium, of the land of the Latins,
所以如果我们接受休息前提出的论点，即伟大的转折点是公元前390年，高卢人洗劫罗马，以及罗马人从那时起绝不再冒这种羞辱风险的决心。也许他们花了几年时间来锻造这种新社会，一种将对荣誉的追求转化为可以针对罗马邻居的东西的社会。好吧，到了公元前340年代，罗马周围所有的拉丁城市都完全从属于罗马的权威。其中许多已被登记在罗马本身的公民团体中。接下来发生了什么？波利比乌斯所确定的这种对武力的依赖，在意大利政治的背景下是如何表现出来的？所以拉提姆（Latium），拉丁人土地的南部，
there is Campania, which is Naples, Capua, both of them Greek cities, Pompeii, sheltering under Mount Vesuvius, rich, prosperous, civilized. But up in the mountains, you have a people called the Samnites, very hardy warriors, whose ancestors supposedly were led there from not far from Rome by, depending on who told the story, a bull or a wolf or a woodpecker. God, you wouldn't want to be led by a woodpecker, would you? I'd choose the wolf. I think I would. I was thinking about this. I think I would choose him because at least you wouldn't lose him, would you? I mean, you'd always be able to hear him
有坎帕尼亚（Campania），也就是那不勒斯、卡普阿，它们都是希腊城市，庞贝，在维苏威火山下避难，富有、繁荣、文明。但在山上，有一群人叫萨姆尼特人（Samnites），非常强悍的战士，他们的祖先据说是被一只公牛、一只狼或一只啄木鸟从离罗马不远的地方带到那里的。天哪，你不会想被一只啄木鸟带路，对吧？我会选择狼。我想我会的。我一直在想这个。我想我会选择它，因为至少你不会弄丢它，对吧？我的意思是，你总是能听到它
knocking on a tree. Yeah, but it's so demeaning. I think a bull, fine, but a wolf is better and a woodpecker is definitely third. Anyway. Okay, so you're not team woodpecker. No.
敲树。是啊，但这太贬低人了。我觉得公牛还行，但狼更好，啄木鸟绝对排第三。总之。好吧，看来你不是啄木鸟队的。不。
Anyway, so these are people who are viewed even by the Romans as being very, very savage. They're notorious for practicing witchcraft. They wear great heavy rings of iron around their neck and they're supposedly given to shaving their private parts in public. Again, this is the woodpecker issue, isn't it? I mean, this is what happens when you go down that road. And they will live long in the Roman imagination, you know, for centuries afterwards, because they are given to wearing very thick belts and helmets with great bobbing crests.
总之，这些人即使在罗马人眼中也被视为非常、非常野蛮。他们因实行巫术而臭名昭著。他们脖子上戴着沉重的铁环，据说还喜欢在公共场合剃掉私处的毛发。再说一次，这就是啄木鸟的问题，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是你走上那条路后的下场。他们将在罗马人的想象中长期存在，你知道，在随后的几个世纪里，因为他们喜欢佩戴非常厚的腰带和带有巨大晃动冠饰的头盔。
And this is a style that will become very popular with gladiators. So you think the classic image of the gladiator with its bobbing crest and its great big belt. This is Samnite armor. And so they are viewed by certainly the people down in the plains of campania with contempt not unreasonably i would say tom so the greeks particularly yeah and so the very hostile relations between sam knights and the campaign so sam knights are always coming down trying to kind of bully and intimidate the capuans or the neapolitans kind of go off with their cattle that kind of thing and so in the second half of the fourth century,
这种风格后来在角斗士中变得非常流行。所以你会想到角斗士的经典形象，带着晃动的冠饰和巨大的腰带。这就是萨姆尼特人的盔甲。因此，坎帕尼亚平原上的人们当然对他们怀有蔑视，我觉得这并不无道理，汤姆，尤其是希腊人。是的，萨姆尼特人和坎帕尼亚人之间的关系非常敌对，所以萨姆尼特人总是跑下来试图欺负和恐吓卡普亚人或那不勒斯人，抢走他们的牛之类的东西。所以在四世纪下半叶，
the Romans, who are now the great power in central Italy, get sucked into this. And they kind of come in on the side of Capua. They start fighting against the Samnites. They then get distracted by the Latin uprising. And when they resume hostilities in 341, the Samnites immediately come to terms. The Romans patch up an alliance with the Samnites. The Campanians are now siding with the Latins. It's all very confusing. But I think what is obvious from this kind of whole confusing melange of Romans fighting Samnites on behalf of the Campanians, and the Campanians are then fighting with the Latins against the Romans, it's all incredibly balkan. What's clear is that the Romans are basically going to be going to war
现在是意大利中部大国的罗马人被卷入了这场纷争。他们站在卡普亚一边介入。他们开始与萨姆尼特人作战。然后他们被拉丁人的起义分散了注意力。当他们在341年恢复敌对行动时，萨姆尼特人立即达成协议。罗马人与萨姆尼特人修补了联盟。坎帕尼亚人现在站在拉丁人一边。这一切非常令人困惑。但我认为，从这种罗马人代表坎帕尼亚人与萨姆尼特人作战，而坎帕尼亚人随后又与拉丁人一起对抗罗马人的混乱局面中，显而易见的是，这一切简直太巴尔干化了。显而易见的是，罗马人基本上要与萨姆尼特人开战。
with the Samnites. And so it turns out, because in 326, war blazes out again, and this will last for 22 years. And the Romans carry it on despite the fact that they suffer one of their most humiliating defeats when they get trapped in a narrow valley called the Cordine Forks. And the Sabines, rather than massacring them, they play by the rules because there are accepted rules in Italian warfare. If you capture your enemy, you force them to submit. So you make a yoke, you have two spears stuck in the ground, and then you put another spear across it. And the defeated army has to thread beneath this yoke. They have to agree to end the war, and they have to accept the terms of the conqueror. So in this context, after the defeat
结果确实如此，因为在326年，战争再次爆发，并将持续22年。尽管罗马人在被困在考迪乌姆峡谷这个狭窄山谷时遭受了最屈辱的失败之一，但他们还是坚持了下来。萨宾人（萨姆尼特人）没有屠杀他们，而是遵守规则，因为意大利战争中有公认的规则。如果你俘虏了敌人，你就强迫他们投降。所以你做一个轭，把两根长矛插在地上，然后横放另一根长矛。战败的军队必须从这个轭下穿过。他们必须同意结束战争，并接受征服者的条件。所以在这个背景下，在考迪乌姆峡谷战败后，
of the Chaldean forks, two Roman consuls who had been in charge of the army agree that they will withdraw what the Romans called coloniae, which are colonies, the English word comes from, which are kind of plantations of Romans in enemy territory. So the Romans have planted coloniae in Samnium and the condition of their army being allowed to go is that they will withdraw this and they swear this to the gods and all this kind of thing. But what about this thing about the Romans would endure any suffering rather than be humiliated? Right, exactly. So when the defeated legions come down from Samnium into Campania, they're too humiliated even to show their faces in Capua. They're so embarrassed. They feel they've let the Capuans down, they've let the Romans down,
两名负责军队的罗马执政官同意撤回罗马人所说的“殖民地”（coloniae），也就是英语单词的来源，这是一种在敌方领土上的罗马人种植园。所以罗马人在萨姆尼乌姆建立了殖民地，而允许他们军队离开的条件是他们必须撤回这些殖民地，他们向神发誓，诸如此类。但关于罗马人宁愿忍受任何痛苦也不愿受辱的说法呢？对，没错。所以当战败的军团从萨姆尼乌姆撤回坎帕尼亚时，他们甚至羞于在卡普亚露面。他们太尴尬了。他们觉得辜负了卡普亚人，辜负了罗马人，
but worst of all, they've let themselves down. And when they get back home to Rome, they just go and lock themselves up in their homes and won't come out. And so the shame of this is something that is clearly insufferable. And so one of the consuls who has agreed to the terms stands up in the Senate and says, look guys, it was me and my consular colleague who agreed this. You, the Roman people, did not agree this. So you can carry on the war. Of course, this will require me and my colleague to be handed over naked and shackled to the Samnites. But because we are patriotic Romans, we are willing to accept that. And so this is what happens. The Romans return to war. The consuls are given to the Samnites. The Samnites don't know what to do with them, so send them back because they're still playing by the traditional rules. The Romans embark on a kind of total war, endless grueling sequence of campaigns. But by 304, the Samnites have no choice but to sue for terms. There's another
但最糟糕的是，他们辜负了自己。当他们回到罗马家中时，他们只是把自己锁在屋里，不肯出来。所以这种耻辱显然是无法忍受的。于是，其中一位同意条件的执政官站出来在元老院说，看，伙计们，是我和我的执政官同事同意的。你们，罗马人民，并没有同意。所以你们可以继续战争。当然，这需要我和我的同事赤身裸体、戴着镣铐被交给萨姆尼特人。但因为我们是爱国的罗马人，我们愿意接受这一点。于是事情就这样发生了。罗马人重返战争。执政官被交给萨姆尼特人。萨姆尼特人不知道该拿他们怎么办，所以把他们送了回来，因为他们仍然遵守传统的规则。罗马人开始了某种全面战争，一系列无休止的艰苦战役。但到了304年，萨姆尼特人别无选择，只能求和。
cycle of war that breaks out in 298. But by 290, the Samnites have been decisively defeated. Roman colonies are planted across their land. The Samnites have been decisively defeated. Roman colonies are planted across their land, the Samnites themselves are forced to become allies of Rome, much of their land is annexed, and essentially the Samnites are now being absorbed into the apparatus of the Roman war machine. Meanwhile, even as the Romans have been fighting the Samnites, they've also been going northwards, attacking the Etruscan cities, conquering them, absorbing them into their framework of alliances. Even the Gauls in the north of Italy are being forced to submit. And by 285, so this is within the lifetime since that treaty with Carthage was signed, the Romans have conquered pretty much the whole of Italy.
298年又爆发了一轮战争。但到了290年，萨姆尼特人已被彻底击败。罗马殖民地遍布他们的土地。萨姆尼特人本身被迫成为罗马的盟友，他们的大部分土地被吞并，本质上萨姆尼特人现在正被吸收到罗马战争机器的机构中。与此同时，即使在罗马人与萨姆尼特人作战的同时，他们也一直在向北进军，攻击伊特鲁里亚城市，征服它们，并将它们吸收到他们的联盟框架中。甚至意大利北部的凯尔特人也被迫投降。到了285年，也就是自与迦太基签署条约以来的有生之年内，罗马人几乎征服了整个意大利。
And all that remains really independent is the Greek cities in the south. So Magna Graeca, as the Romans called it. So to just pause a second and look to Carthage, the Carthaginians at that point do not have colonies and territories on the mainland of Italy and never have. Is that right? They have trading colonies.
剩下的真正独立的只有南部的希腊城市。也就是罗马人所称的大希腊。所以暂停一下，看看迦太基，迦太基人在那个时候在意大利大陆上没有殖民地和领土，从来没有过。对吗？他们有贸易殖民地。
So they're kind of like... The sort of Hong Kong and Singapore type places. Not exactly because they're not administered by the Carthaginians, but there are kind of colonies of Carthaginian merchants within all these various cities. And that is what the treaties have agreed to. But they haven't been conquered by the Romans or they have? They have been conquered by the Romans, yeah. But the Romans are just letting the Carthaginian merchants in those places crack on with it.
所以他们有点像……那种香港和新加坡类型的地方。不完全是，因为它们不是由迦太基人管理的，但在所有这些不同的城市里都有迦太基商人的殖民地。这就是条约所同意的。但他们没有被罗马人征服，还是他们被征服了？他们被罗马人征服了，是的。但罗马人只是让那些地方的迦太基商人继续做生意。
Yes, because the Romans treaty with Carthage provides for cities that are dominated by Rome. Okay. So the provisions of the treaty with Rome now governs the whole of Italy. Understood. So Rome and Carthage are still allies at this point. Yeah. And actually, the fact that Rome is now gearing up to attack the Greek colonies in the south of Italy, the area that had been settled, much as
是的，因为罗马与迦太基的条约规定了由罗马统治的城市。好的。所以现在与罗马的条约条款管辖着整个意大利。明白了。所以罗马和迦太基此时仍然是盟友。是的。事实上，罗马现在正准备攻击意大利南部的希腊殖民地，这个地区和西西里岛一样，南部意大利也曾被希腊殖民者定居。希腊人是迦太基人的敌人。罗马人现在正试图攻击希腊人。所以迦太基人和罗马人仍然有充分的理由成为盟友。南部最强大的希腊城市是塔兰托，由斯巴达人在几个世纪前建立，并保留了那种军事传统。但罗马人显然太强大了，塔兰托人无法独自抵抗。所以他们寻找盟友。幸运的是，对于塔兰托人来说，这样的盟友就在亚得里亚海的另一边，在伊庇鲁斯的多山王国，大概在阿尔巴尼亚那一带。它的国王是一个叫皮洛士的人，我希望他不会
Sicily had been, southern Italy also had been settled by Greek colonists. The Greeks are the enemies of the Carthaginians. The Romans are now having a crack at the Greeks. So there's every reason for the Carthaginians and the Romans still to be allies. And the most powerful Greek city in the south is Tarentum, founded by the Spartans many centuries before and preserving that kind of military tradition. But the Romans are clearly too powerful for the Tarentines on their own to resist. And so they look around for an ally. And fortunately for the Tarentines, such an ally is there just on the other side of the Adriatic in the mountainous kingdom of Epirus, kind of around Albania, that kind of area. And its king is a guy called pyrrhus i hope he doesn't
赢得一场皮洛士式的胜利，汤姆。嗯，皮洛士，他非常想成为亚历山大大帝，对吧？他被困在这种多山的准马其顿王国里，是的，他想要荣耀的空间，他是一位非常、非常精通的将军。他在东地中海到处炫耀，赢得了各种胜利，但他确实与西方有联系，因为他娶了阿加托克利斯的女儿，阿加托克利斯是叙拉古的暴君，我们在上一集谈到过。所以当塔兰托人的邀请传来时，皮洛士看了一眼，他想，是的，意大利南部，西西里岛，这里有荣耀的空间。于是他带着一支庞大的军队越过亚得里亚海，其中第一次在意大利战斗中出现了战象。好的，我们可以停下来谈谈大象吗？
win a pyrrhic victory tom well so pyrrhus is he's very much an alexander the great wannabe right he's stuck in this kind of mountainous sub-macedonian kingdom yeah and he wants scope for glory and he's a very very proficient general he's been kind of swaggering around the eastern mediterranean scoring all kinds of victories but he does have links to the west because he's a very, very proficient general. He's been kind of swaggering around the Eastern Mediterranean, scoring all kinds of victories. But he does have links to the West because he's married to the daughter of Agathocles, who's the tyrant of Syracuse, who we talked about in the previous episode. So when the invitation from the Tarentines come, Pyrrhus looks over, he thinks, yeah, Southern Italy, Sicily, scope here for glory. And so he crosses the Adriatic with an enormous army that features, for the first time in Italian combat, war elephants. Okay, can we stop and talk about the elephants for a second?
因为我喜欢历史上的大象。他拥有的大象大概是因为作为伊庇鲁斯国王，他和马其顿希腊化世界的一部分，他大概是从塞琉古帝国，从亚洲的希腊帝国那里得到的，我猜。是的，它们来自印度。红海有一个巨大的深水港，巨大的船只带着大象来到那里，基本上你可以从那里采购大象，或者你可以从叙利亚的国王那里采购大象，他们可以通过陆路通道。所以是的，这就是你如何得到大象的方法。或者有一种现在已经灭绝的特殊大象在北非。
Because I love an elephant on the rest of history. The elephants he has presumably got because as king of Epirus, he and part of the kind of Macedonian Hellenistic world, he presumably has got those from the Seleucids, from the Greek Empire in Asia, I'm guessing. Yeah, they've come from India. There's a great deep water port on the Red Sea where vast ships come with elephants and basically you can source elephants from there or you can source elephants from the kings in Syria who have access across the land channels. So yeah, this is how you get elephants. Or there's a particular kind of elephant that is now extinct that is in North Africa.
所以这就是迦太基人得到他们大象的地方。是这样吗？是的。所以如果你想要大象，它们是可以得到的。对。为什么不呢？皮洛士确实想要它们。说得对。
So this is where the Carthaginians get their elephants. Is that so? Yeah. So elephants are available if you want them. Right. And why wouldn't you? And Pyrrhus does want them. Quite right too.
因为，当然，马害怕大象。对。为什么不呢？皮洛士确实想要它们。说得对。因为当然，马害怕大象。是的。你知道，骑兵冲锋时，你看到一头大象，它们全都尖叫着向后逃跑。当然，
Because, of course, horses are terrified of elephants. Right. And why wouldn't you? And Pyrrhus does want them. Quite right too. Because of course, horses are terrified of elephants. Yeah. You know, cavalry charging along and you see an elephant and they all go screaming off in reverse. And of course,
它们可以冲进步兵阵线，让步兵溃散。太可怕了。汤姆，关于大象的问题，我知道我们不是在讲军事历史，但我相信大象的问题
they can go crashing into a line of infantry, stampede them. Terrifying. The issue with elephants, Tom, I know we're not the rest of military history, but I believe the issue
在于大象很容易受到惊吓，并会冲撞自己的一方。这始终是一个风险。所以它们可能是一个巨大的负担。它们可能是。但如果你像皮洛士一样是一位顶级将军，你就知道如何控制它们。是的。所以皮洛士在280年登陆意大利，他带来了大量战象。他带来了
with elephants is that elephants can easily be frightened and will stampede their own side. That is constantly a risk. So they can be a tremendous liability. They can be. But if you're a top general like Pyrrhus, you know how to control them. Yeah. And so Pyrrhus in 280, he lands in Italy and he brings a whole load of war elephants. He brings
他的骑兵，马其顿骑兵很有名。当然，他带来了他的方阵，你知道，非常长的长矛，这种战争工具使亚历山大能够征服波斯帝国。巨大的创新。所以罗马人现在进入了大联盟。我的意思是，再次使用足球类比，这是冠军联赛。他们现在正面临地中海存在的最可怕的战争方式。他们会怎么做？
his cavalry, Macedonian cavalry is famous. And of course he brings his phalanx, you know, enormously long spears, the instrument of war that had enabled Alexander to conquer the Persian empire. Tremendous innovation. So the Romans are now in the big league. I mean, again, to pursue the football analogy, this is the Champions League. They are now facing the most terrifying way of making war that exists in the Mediterranean. How are they going to do?
好吧，他们在赫拉克利亚相遇，罗马人和皮洛士的军队，在意大利南部。大象被带了出来。罗马马匹被吓坏了。它们逃跑了。罗马人输了，但这是一场非常血腥的胜利。罗马人给皮洛士造成了大量伤亡。皮洛士也遵守规则。他不想征服罗马并摧毁它。他假设在赢得胜利后，罗马人现在会进行谈判。于是他派了一个使团到罗马，他提供了，是的，非常合理的条件。所以他说，我会释放我俘虏的囚犯。我会帮助你们征服意大利的其他地区。
Well, they meet at a place called Heraclea, the Romans and Pyrrhus' army, which is in southern Italy. The elephants are brought out. The Roman horses are terrified. They scarper. The Romans lose, but it's a very bloody victory. The Romans inflict a lot of casualties on Pyrrhus. Pyrrhus is also playing by the rules. He doesn't want to conquer Rome and destroy it. He assumes that having won his victory, the Romans will now negotiate. And so he sends an embassy to Rome and he offers, yeah, very reasonable terms. So he says, I'll free the prisoners that I've taken. I'll help you with the subjugation of the rest of Italy.
你们所要做的就是给予塔兰托豁免权。元老院很想接受这些条件。我的意思是，它们看起来非常好。但随后你有了这位可怕的、顽固的老参议员，他是克劳狄家族的阿庇乌斯·克劳狄。他就是修建阿庇亚大道的人，这条伟大的道路从罗马一直延伸到意大利的脚跟，就像一条投在萨姆尼乌姆山脉上的锁链，使罗马人能够随心所欲地打击。他是盲人，所以被称为“盲眼的卡埃库斯”。他站起来，基本上说，永远不要投降。我们永远不会与意大利的入侵者谈判。他有这句名言，每个人都是自己命运的建筑师，暗示每个公民内心都有成为罗马命运建筑师的能力。
All you've got to do is give immunity to Tarentum. And the Senate is tempted to accept these terms. I mean, they seem very good. But then you have this terrifyingly craggy old senator who is a Claudian, Appius Claudius. And he is the guy who builds the Appian Way, the great road that runs from Rome down to the heel of Italy, and is like a chain that has been cast over the mountains of Samnium, enabling the Romans to strike where they want. He is blind, so he's called Caicus the Blind. He stands up and he basically says, never surrender. We are never going to negotiate with an invader of Italy. He has this famous line, every man is the architect of his own destiny, with the implication that every citizen has it within him to be the architect
罗马人继续战斗。第二年，279年，又发生了一场战斗，皮洛士又赢了一次。但同样，他的方阵、他的骑兵、他的大象都受到了非常、非常严重的伤害。就在这时，他发表了那句名言，再来一次这样的胜利，我就彻底完了。所以这就是“皮洛士式的胜利”这个词的来源。他决定受够了。他想，你知道，我不想继续和罗马人打仗了。我不会剩下任何人的。于是他去了西西里岛与迦太基人作战。他被西西里希腊人邀请到那里。他们想要另一个希腊人来帮助他们打击迦太基人，这是他们一直在做的事情。皮洛士很想让他的孙子，也就是阿加托克利斯的孙子，因为皮洛士娶了阿加托克利斯的女儿，成为叙拉古的国王。所以基本上他试图在叙拉古建立他的王朝。所以他去了并做了这件事。但皮洛士不幸表现得如此傲慢，以至于所有的希腊人都对他感到愤怒，他们倒戈并与迦太基人结盟。所以皮洛士和希腊人已经
of Rome's destiny. The Romans carry on the fight. The following year, 279, there's another battle, another victory for Pyrrhus. But again, his phalanx, his cavalry, his elephants are very, very badly maimed. And it's at this point that he makes the famous comment, another victory like this, and it will be the ruin of me. So this is exactly where the phrase Pyrrhic victory comes from. And he decides he's had enough. He thinks, you know, I don't want to keep fighting the Romans. I won't have anybody left. And so he goes off to Sicily to fight the Carthaginians. He's invited there by the Sicilian Greeks. They want another Greek to help them have a crack at the Carthaginians, which they're always doing. And Pyrrhus is keen to install his grandson, who is Agathocles' grandson as well, because Pyrrhus has married Agathocles' daughter, to become king of Syracuse. So basically he's trying to establish his dynasty in Syracuse. So he goes off and does that. But Pyrrhus unfortunately behaves in such a kind of arrogant manner that all the Greeks get pissed off with him and they switch sides and team up with the Carthaginians. So Pyrrhus and the Greeks have
分道扬镳了。所以皮洛士现在发现自己同时在与迦太基人和希腊人作战。他想，你知道，受够了。所以他回到了意大利。但在那里，他发现罗马人不可避免地加强了他们的力量。又发生了一场战斗。同样，这是不分胜负的。同样，罗马人给皮洛士造成了毁灭性的伤亡。他决定他受够了。
split up. So Pyrrhus now finds himself fighting both the Carthaginians and the Greeks. And he thinks, you know, had enough of this. So he heads back to Italy. But there he finds that the Romans have built up their forces, inevitably. There's another battle. Again, it's indecisive. Again, the Romans inflict devastating casualties on Pyrrhus. And he decides that he's had enough.
于是他收拾行装回家了。这基本上是皮洛士在意大利的最后一次交战。272年，他去了希腊南部，进入伯罗奔尼撒半岛。他卷入了一场在阿尔戈斯的街头战斗，他正在和一个家伙打架。那个家伙的母亲在屋顶上，你知道，看到她心爱的儿子在和皮洛士打架，伸手拿了一块屋顶瓦片，向皮洛士扔去，砸中了他的脑袋，杀死了他。这就是皮洛士的结局。
And so he packs up and goes home. And that basically is the last that Pyrrhus is engaged in Italy. And in 272, he goes off into Southern Greece, into the Peloponnese. He gets involved in a street battle in Argos and he's fighting with this guy. And the guy's mother is up on the roof, you know, sees her beloved boy fighting Pyrrhus, reaches for a roof tile, hurls it at Pyrrhus, brains him and it kills him. And so that's the end of Pyrrhus, reaches for a roof tile, hurls it at Pyrrhus, brains him, and it kills him. And so that's the end of Pyrrhus.
皮洛士的结局真是令人沮丧。是的，非常悲伤。对狮心王来说非常丰富。但与此同时，在意大利，他一走，罗马人就进入塔兰托，占领了它。基本上意大利的征服完成了。关于皮洛士只有一件事。所有关于罗马人不可战胜、才华横溢之类的说法。我的意思是，他们没有打败皮洛士。皮洛士赢了。不，他们没有。但皮洛士，是的，他确实有效地赢得了这三场战斗，但他没有赢得战争，因为罗马人不断回来。并不是说罗马人期望赢得每一场战斗，但他们期望赢得每一场战争。对。因为他们的人力，汤姆。无论他们输掉多少场战斗，他们总是会回来。当然，这将是罗马随后与迦太基人进行的战争中的一个关键主题。对。你知道，这就像九头蛇。
What a depressing end for Pyrrhus. Yeah, very sad. Very rich for the Lionheart. But meanwhile, back in Italy, the moment he goes, the Romans move into Tarentum, take it. And basically the conquest of Italy is complete. Just one thing on Pyrrhus. All that stuff about the Romans being invincible and brilliant and stuff. I mean, they didn't be Pyrrhus. Pyrrhus. All that stuff about the Romans being invincible and
你砍掉一个头，另一个又长出来了。是的。但在这一点上，随着整个意大利成功平定，皮洛士被送走，罗马和迦太基之间的关系保持稳定。迦太基人并不反对罗马征服意大利。事实上，348年，也就是他们即将开始一系列伟大征服的时候，他们已经开始与萨姆尼特人作战。罗马人在萨姆尼特人身上赢得了一场特定的战斗，迦太基人送给他们一顶非常奢华的金冠，
brilliant and stuff. I mean, they didn't be Pyrrhus. Pyrrhus won. No, they didn't. But Pyrrhus, yes, he does effectively win the three battles, but he doesn't win the war because the Romans keep coming back. And it's not that the Romans expect to win every battle, but they expect to win every war. Right. Because of their manpower, Tom. It doesn't matter how many battles they lose, they will always come back. And this, of course, will be a key theme in the wars that Rome goes on to fight with the Carthaginians. Right. You know, it's like the Hydra.
罗马人后来把它保存在卡皮托利山上作为一种纪念品。此时罗马确实有迦太基人。罗马有一个完整的区域叫Vicus Africus，埃斯奎林山上的非洲区，以迦太基人命名。拉丁语中市场的词，即machelum，源自腓尼基语，甚至在后来的罗马作家中有模糊的暗示，在罗马的水果市场竖立着一种叫betel的神圣石头，所以根据条约条款，确实有迦太基人的存在，迦太基商人在罗马和从属于罗马的城市中自由走动。关于迦太基的最后一件事。他们这段时间一直在做什么？所以只是
You chop a head off, another one sprouts back up. Yeah. But at this point, with the whole of Italy successfully pacified, with Pyrrhus seen off, conditions between Rome and Carthage remain stable. The Carthaginians are not opposed to Rome conquering Italy. In fact, 348, so this is right when they're just about to embark on their great series of conquests, and they've started fighting the Samnites. The Romans win a particular battle over the Samnites, and the Carthaginians send them a tremendously lavish golden crown,
大概有一连串叫马戈和汉诺之类的人，只是互换着赚了很多钱。他们一直在与叙拉古人作战。好的。我们在上一集谈到过。是的。在那之后，他们一直在舔舐伤口。他们一直在试图重建他们的力量，雇佣更多的雇佣兵，建立他们的舰队。所以这就是为什么当皮洛士这个希腊国王来的时候，迦太基人认为皮洛士是主要敌人。
which the Romans then keep on the capital as a kind of a memento. There are definitely Carthaginians in Rome at this point. There's an entire area of Rome that's called the Vicus Africus, the African quarter on the Esquiline Hill, named after the Carthaginians. The Latin word for market, which is machelum, to derive from the phoenician and there are even vague hints in later roman writers that there's a betel which is a kind of sacred stone erected in the fruit market in rome so there is a carthaginian presence as per the terms of the treaty carthaginian merchants are moving freely around rome and the cities that are subordinate to rome and just one last thing on carthage. What have they been doing all this time? So there's just
这就是为什么他们很高兴与罗马人结盟。他们不认为罗马人是像皮洛士那样的威胁，本质上是因为迦太基人，就像西西里岛的希腊人和意大利的所有人一样，他们需要时间来弄清楚他们在罗马面对的是什么。地中海西部每个人都接受了一些战斗规则。它可能非常残酷。城市可能被摧毁等等。但总的来说，这种情况并没有发生。总的来说，这就像一种残酷的运动，每年你出去，你知道，你进行一场战斗，你进行一场战争等等，
been presumably a succession of people called Mago and Hanno and stuff, just interchangeably kind of making loads of money. They have been fighting the Syracusans. Okay. Which we talked about in the previous episode. Yeah. In the wake of that, they've been licking their wounds. They've been trying to rebuild their forces, hire more mercenaries, build up their fleet. And so this is why when Pyrrhus comes, a Greek king, the Carthaginians assume that Pyrrhus is the major enemy.
但随后你签署条约。你不是为了行使全面统治而出去。是的。但当然，这就是罗马人的目的。但迦太基人并不是真的，你知道，他们还没有在那个特定的事实上被摩擦过鼻子。所以你可能会认为随着皮洛士在迦太基的撤退，你会想，好吧，太好了。我们送走了这位马其顿国王。西西里岛的希腊人现在与我们结盟。我们与罗马结盟。我们在西西里岛西部有我们的势力范围。一切都很好。
And this is why they're happy to be in alliance with the Romans. They don't think of the Romans as being a threat comparable to Pyrrhus, essentially because the Carthaginians, like the Greeks in Sicily and like everybody in Italy, it takes time for them to work out what they're facing in Rome. There are kind of rules of combat that everyone in the Western Mediterranean has accepted. It can be very brutal. Cities can be destroyed or whatever. But by and large, that doesn't happen. By and large, it is like a kind of brutal form of sport that every year you go out, you know, you have a battle, you have a war or whatever,
但皮洛士已经认识到了即将发生的事情，因为据说当他在西西里岛时，就在他离开回意大利之前，他环顾四周说，我们在这里为罗马人和迦太基人留下了一个多么美丽的杀戮场。他没有错，多米尼克，因为在他离开意大利后的10年内，罗马和迦太基将处于战争状态。哦，天哪，汤姆，真是个悬念。正如克里斯·莫里斯所说，这是战争。你知道吗，这就像
but then you sign treaties. You're not going out there to exercise total domination. Yeah. But of course, this is what the Romans are about. But the Carthaginians are not really, you know, they haven't had their noses rubbed in that particular fact yet. And so you might think with the withdrawal of Pyrrhus in Carthage, you'd think, well, great. We've seen off this Macedonian king. The Greeks in Sicily are now allied with us. We're allied with Rome. We have our sphere of influence in Western Sicily. Everything's great.
我们做过的最像劳伦斯·奥利弗《战争世界》的古代世界播客。你太客气了。有你作为劳伦斯·奥利弗。绝对迷人的东西。令人难以置信的兴奋。听着，我不敢相信有人会乐意等，什么，三天来听这个系列的最后一集，
But Pyrrhus had recognized what was to come because it is said that while he was in Sicily, just before he leaves to go back to Italy, he looks around him and he says, what a beautiful killing field we are leaving here in Sicily for the Romans and the Carthaginians. And he's not wrong, Dominic, because within 10 years of his departure from Italy, Roman Carthage will be at war. Oh my word, Tom, what a cliffhanger. As Chris Morris would say, it's war. Do you know what, this is like
也就是罗马和迦太基之间的世界大战。如果你处于那种必须等待的位置，你实际上现在就可以听，因为你所要做的就是去therestishistory.com，点击几下，你就会进入Rest is History俱乐部，这很棒。然后你可以听那一集。如果没有，恐怕你将不得不等几天，谁知道在此期间会发生什么。所以不要冒那个险。加入俱乐部，听这一集，然后加入那些走过
the ancient world podcast we've ever done to Laurence Olivier's The World at War. You're too kind. With you as Laurence Olivier. Absolutely fascinating stuff. Incredibly exciting. Listen, I can't believe there's anybody who would happily wait, what, three days to hear the final episode of this series,
街道，欢呼汤姆·霍兰德名字的人群。他们非常喜欢它。在那颗重磅炸弹上，再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开了娱乐的帷幕
which is World War between Rome and Carthage. And if you're in that position where you are going to have to wait, you can actually listen to it right now, because all you have to do is go to therestishistory.com, a couple of clicks, you'll be in the Rest is History Club, which is brilliant. And then you can listen to that episode. If not, I'm afraid you'll have to wait several days and who knows what could happen in the intervening period. So don't take that risk. Join the club, listen to the episode, and then join the throngs of people going through the
我们告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
streets, cheering Tom Holland's name. They've enjoyed it so much. And on that bombshell, goodbye. Goodbye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment
街道上，人们欢呼着汤姆·赫兰德的名字。他们非常享受这一切。带着这个重磅消息，再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕后真相
and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及优先购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。